what we have here
is karim carr who is a phd student
at harvard who made a big splash
several months ago on the topic of what
on earth two plus two
might possibly equal and his point was
all of you who think it's four are
failing to grasp just how subjective and
arbitrary
mathematics is and so in any case the
world descended into madness over this
uh for some time now two plus two equals
five
is also uh an oblique reference to
orwell 1984. this is um
i don't know is it newspeak or it's some
sort of
it's it's one of the modes by which you
force a population to totalitarianism if
you can get people to agree
that two plus two equals five well
you're well on your way
right and just um the the kerfuffle from
many months back
was lead on the side of no two plus two
actually does equal four um by our
friend jim lindsey
yes um so any way most people will
remember that if they are on twitter at
least they will have
seen some part of that battle and kareem
has
decided to blow on the embers of that
battle
to see if he can rekindle it and i what
has he said so we can just
yeah i'll just get this off he's got two
tweets here he says
when someone says two plus two equals
four in a really angry way they're
admitting that the statement can't what
the statement can't do for itself
one can't calmly state it like a fact it
is it supposedly is
one must back it up with the threat of
force to make it stick
and this act affirms the spirit of two
plus two equals five he goes on
and he says so even when they think
they've won the argument
they're losing their defensiveness and
anger is
already a loss because it brings two
plus two equals four
into the subjective where it belongs
so those two last points being angry
brings the statement into the subjective
and the subject the subjective is where
it belongs yeah
now so the reason to be here is not just
simply to harp
on the absurdity of what kareem khar is
saying and to try to parse it and
finally get it right so people
can finally understand why two plus two
equals four because as i said to him the
first time through this
what he is engaged in is a classic
example of sophistry
which is to say his argument is hard to
field which doesn't say anything about
its being right
and his argument if you go back to his
original claim had to do with the fact
that the symbols
two and five and equals and plus
are all something that we simply agree
on and there's no reason to agree that
they equal this or that
and so they could equal other things and
therefore the statement two plus two
equals five could be a totally
reasonable statement as good as two plus
two equals four and the answer is
that's not just sophistry i mean that's
but colloquially people mean when they
say
semantics and it's not actually some
adjectives it's not
just sophistry but he's not a phd
student just anywhere
it's harvard level sophistry yeah right
so
anyway that is what it is that's not
really the point
to return here the reason i wanted to
return is that it struck me when i saw
his new argument
that this was actually an interesting
opportunity so
uh several years back i think 2017 i
gave
a talk in vancouver
that i called how the magic trick is
done and how the magic
was done was basically a sort of a
taxonomy of tricks
and kafka traps and uh other
things that are causing um
the social justice ideology to actually
wield a great deal of power in spite of
the fact
that the arguments that it's making are
um
not correct in many regards and
what one does not typically see so one
of the things i said in that talk
is that these techniques evolve
people try a lot of stuff and the stuff
that doesn't work
doesn't leave a fossil right the stuff
that works
gets picked up on and it gets augmented
and it gets built into a very refined
strategic
structure that we realize needs to be
talked about at the point that it comes
for us and we can't field it because
even though
we may be right about something it is
very difficult to figure out how you
deal
with the incentive surrounding so this
kareem car
next chapter here struck me as the rare
case where you might be present for the
birth of a new technique
right if you think about his argument
here
if people say two plus two equals four
and they get angry about it then their
anger is an indication that two plus two
does not
inherently equal four right well this is
an amazing argument
right this is stunning because what this
says
is first of all two plus two equals four
is a baseline nearly
foundational level of societal agreement
right we have to agree with these
symbols mean you know if we're going to
establish truth at all we've got to
establish what the meaning of words is
what the meaning of symbols is what
the operations that they dictate are and
when somebody asserts
that two plus two equals four is not
inherently
true they are attacking something
fundamental i mean you you know if you
imagine if we were to invalidate two
plus two equals four so two plus two
suddenly equals question mark
the modern world ceases to function
instantly
right there's no device that we're using
that doesn't depend on that level of
agreement and a great many things
stacked on top of it
it's like um many years ago our younger
son toby asked me
what would it be like here if there was
no gravity
and it's it's exactly that there
wouldn't be there's no here right
no nothing nothing that we know has
happened
in that world and the same is true for
two plus two equals
what now right exactly so in some sense
what car is saying is we have the right
to attack
the very foundations of systematic
thought
and we have a right to do so in a
politically charged environment where
those of us who are doing that are
actually dictating policy
not only are we saying two plus two
equals five but defund the police
is you know a reasonable thing to demand
so it is natural that somebody who
thinks oh my god
how did two plus two equals five get out
of orwell and into the world
and you know why is it marching right
that
could make a person very nervous they
might be right to be nervous
and they might speak with a certain
amount of urgency and say no two plus
two equals four god damn it
right and the point is that has nothing
to do with whether or not two plus two
does or does not equal four that just
has to do with the fact that what is in
jeopardy if it doesn't equal four
is really important yeah so but it's but
it's as you say
a slick rhetorical move that probably
just dies here but maybe not
so i mean this is it's like it's like a
reformulation of ben shapiro's famous
facts don't care about your feelings
this new formulation is feelings about
facts change the facts
yes feeling feelings about facts are
all you need to figure out whether those
facts are in fact factual right
um so and then the final point i would
make is
i i want people to understand just how
beautiful and diabolical his formulation
is right so let's
say that let's give him the benefit of
the doubt here and let's say
okay for the uh for the
purposes of this argument his uh
assumption is to be taken literally if a
person responds
angrily to the idea that two plus two
equals five then they imply
that two plus two does not equal what
they think it equals okay
now let's apply that across the
population okay
what if all of us but
one decides you know what
i'm gonna say this very calmly two plus
two equals four
my hand does not shake i am not raising
my voice
two plus two simply equals four and that
needs to remain true
right but one person isn't so good at
keeping their
they're calm yeah right they're cool and
they get angry because they're worried
right well that one person has now
invalidated
two plus two equals four and left us in
a world where two plus two
now equals i'm your new king and you
will bow before me
that guy's anger blew up the universe
blew up the universe and so
in any case what i'm hoping is that our
discussing this
here on dark horse will result in
this particular attempt to generate a
new
super weapon failing because people will
realize just how crazy it is
but nonetheless maybe the point is it's
actually sophisticated enough as a
strategy
that in spite of this analysis it will
continue to grow and be augmented and
wielded and we will see it
uh morph into all sorts of things out in
the world
we don't know yet well i mean in part in
part it may well work in part what we're
doing here
may not touch the effectiveness of the
strategy precisely because we are trying
to do analysis
and if the strategy works it will work
exactly on the emotional level
right it will it will affect how people
view things
um because they will have been informed
by the emotional content of people who
are certain that actually if you claim
two plus two equals four well then
you're probably a fascist or some such
yeah uh absolutely so it could be both
we could do the analysis and it actually
might have an influence in a particular
quadrant but
have no impact on uh the utility of this
argument it could still be an
evolutionarily stable strategy even if
it's dead wrong
yes it didn't raise your voice you said
dead wrong in a strong way but the
amplitude was
perfectly a little a little sarcastic
maybe yeah yeah
but that suggests strength oh it doesn't
i think actually oh it works
in reverse okay we're good then
[Music]